oh girl there it
is they're rigging the ballot in Maine
to sabotage Trump's campaign yes they
are on Thursday main Secretary of State
Sheena Bellow removed former president
Trump from the state's primary ballot
proving that Stephen King isn't their
biggest Lefty
idiot the move along with a similar one
by the Colorado Supreme Court is
expected to be ruled on by the US
Supreme Court in the coming weeks as
soon as judge Kavanaugh finishes his
game of beer
pong and last night Bell's acknowledged
she's in territory here while defending
her decision check it out I am so
mindful and I I said this in my decision
uh that it is unprecedented no secretary
of state has ever deprived a
presidential candidate of ballot access
based on section three of the 14th
Amendment but no presidential candidate
has ever engaged in
Insurrection and been disqualified under
section three of the 14th Amendment oh
no you
didn't oh come on translation to that
clip we've seen Biden's poll numbers and
we don't believe him when he says he can
beat President
Reagan Jimmy but not all states are
getting caught up in the calls to remove
Trump from the primary ballots efforts
in Minnesota and Michigan were
unsuccessful and on Thursday California
certified the list of candidates which
does include Trump oddly also on the
California ballot these
men
yeah they're not as shriveled as Joe and
Bernie
uh Florentine I come to you first um you
kind of do look like a guy who stormed
the capital let's be honest which I love
about you thank you you're my buddy uh
but this is so brazenly political and
the reason I say that is he's not
criminally being charged with
Insurrection you want to know why
because you can't overthrow the
government if you're the guy in charge
of the government at the time he was
president was he overthrowing him self
and I thought you had to be found guilty
of something in this country first yeah
no no no it's not it's like okay so CNN
says it was in Insurrection so that
means he's guilty yeah no it's absurd
and the thing is again to your point
because he wasn't charged or convicted
of this crime this is the equivalent of
removing him from the ballot for
something he did in your dream you know
what I'm saying it's like there's no
there's nothing to it and even Gavin
Nome who would you know said no this is
illegal let be on the ballot it's fair
and that's Gavin news coming out and
saying that yeah thank you JB that's
California a state that was so liberal
they wanted to defund the cop and the
Village People okay
so is this is this not proof is this not
proof that this is just a partisan move
just a a political kneecapping I
actually think it's great it actually
applies to my regular life like anytime
I meet somebody in person it's guilty
until proven
innocent and it's true and you have to
prove to me that you're innocent and so
I guess that's uh that's what's
happening with Trump I've never been a
juror uh before either but um if I ever
was a juror I I think that this would
set it awful precedent quite frankly
because you're right he's never been
convicted he was never even charged with
Insurrection so it's not up to these
Democratic leaders the Senators and the
governors to make decisions as to
whether or not he's been convicted or
not of something that he was never
actually charged on um it is purely
political and Ted Cruz put it perfectly
when he said that this is opening a
Pandora's Box and if God forbid a
republican Governor out there were to
come forward and we want to take Joe
Biden off of the ballot what do you
think would happen oh yeah no it would
be hell I mean it would franchising
people yeah people going die that would
not be allowed it would never get to the
Supreme Court the fact that Supreme
Court has to deal with this BS with all
the other crap that's going on under
this government is ridiculous I'm with j
b uh cat let me ask you this okay the
argument here is they're trying to save
democracy by destroying democracy is
this not the equivalent of me protecting
your house from an arsonist by burning
it down kind of and you
know it's also one of these Trump is a
very rich uh powerful person with a hot
wife and like millions of people who are
just devoted and love him and with stuff
like this they managed to then somehow
turn that guy into a victim yeah like
that's the one card he should not be
able to play right but they it it it it
we they also know how much he loves to
get up there at these rallies and talk
about all the ways that the system is
against him right I mean do they not
know that that's clearly his F They just
added so much more time to his set
like and there's no way obviously as
everyone said that this is
constitutional that there's any legal
justification for this I mean it's
obviously absurd that they're saying
they have to do it for democracy I think
that for democracy we're going to remove
you get that's the only have to vote for
this one person to save democracy it's
all absurd but I don't can he be unhappy
about that I doubt it he's probably like
yes
more you know how do they not see that
at this point no that's a great Point
how do they not see
that and Tyler aren't they doing him a
favor by taking him off the ballot Maine
because nobody wants to campaign in
Maine let's be honest it's also funny
cuz everyone in Maine just like me and
my funny friend have what I like to call
resting January 6 face
good job bunch of lobstermen but no it's
it's it's it's more Free Press he loves
it right they've given me billions in
press right Jimmy billions in Free Press
right and now all the other of the
Republicans they're all saying they're
going to take their names off the ballot
VC right V ramaswami Ram which sounds
like a delicious Indian dish right I'll
have the ramaswami and more press more
press you can't say that you can't say
that sir you can't say that I just said
it I just said it he loves it yeah your
Trump impression is so good you're now
on a government watch
list they're now monitoring my texts and
tweets I think Nome said that because he
wasn't going to win California anyway
yeah you know unless he can get somehow
get the homeless to
vote then he win by 20 million
votes but it is true right and Cat made
this point it's just more ammo he did so
do your contention would be Trump likes
this oh I think he absolutely loves it
honestly I mean he was on uh truth
social this afternoon Tweeting or what
do you call it truth thing um I don't
know but anyway he loved it I mean I I
do follow him and he absolutely loves it
and you know the more that people start
to come down on Maga and Trump the more
popular he gets Biden is literally
handing him the presidency with the
amount of bashing that he does on Trump
he needs to worry about himself and like
just walking upstairs and like walking
off Stadium podiums and so forth like
that and just like remembering how to
read a Ard I I just love the idea that
this is this is in material for Trump
because if you've ever covered a trump
rally as I have they are the new Rocky
Horror Picture shows in that everyone
there knows every word to the whole show
like they'll be like bro we can't go to
the bathroom they're about to do lock
her up you know yeah
yeah be back after this up next his
college said he's not allowed to show
that he's well endowed hey hey hey hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else